الوضع الميداني يتغير بين يوم واخر في
اوكرانيا
فبعد تاكيدات اوكرانيا بتقدمها في خرسون
بعد اشهر من السيطره الروسيه عليها يبدو
ان زبريج التي تضم اكبر محطه النوويه في
اوروبا هي الوجهه الثانيه للجيش
الاوكرانيه
عضو مجلس اداره زاكوريجيا اوضح ان الجيش
الاوكراني يعزز ويحصل قواته العسكريه على
خط جبهه
انتقالا من خرسون مؤكدا ان اتجاه ذكوريج
هو الهدف الرئيسي لروسيا حاليا في مسائل
الهجمات والاستفزازات
الخطه الاوكرانيه المعلنه هي الوصول الى
بريديانسك والاستيلاء في نفس الوقت على
بازليفكا وبلجي وعملته بول بالاضافه الى
محور اخر الهجوم من خلال نهر دنبرو
والاستلاء على محطه زابوريجيا للطاقه
النوويه
انقلاب الكفه ميدانيا في هذا التوقيت
يعتبر ضربه قاسمه لظهر موسكو خاصه وان
خلصون وازكوريجيا منطقه ثاني من اربعه كان
بوتن اجرا استفتاء فيهما واعلن ضمهما الى
روسيا في سبتمبر الماضي
لكن موسكو ترفض الاعتراف بالهزيمه فقد
اعلن الكريملين سحب عشرات الالاف من
الجنود من خرصون وانه على الرغم من
الانسحاب تظل المقاطعه باكملها جزءا من
روسيا كما اعتمدت موسكو
عاصمه اداريه لخرصون على بحر ازوف اما
وزاره الدفاع الروسي فقالت انها اكملت
عمليات نقل قواتها من الضفه اليمنى لنهر
دنيرو في مقاطعه خرسون الى الضفه اليسرى
من النهر